BACK OUT TO TOFFOLI.
HIS SHOT IS BLOCKED.
DOWN TO 25 SECONDS REMAINING.
HERE'S SUZUKI.
PUCK IN BEHIND THE TAMPA NET.
McDONAGH IS ON IT THERE.
SUZUKI TAKES A HIT.
DOWN TO 15 SECONDS.
TO THE RIGHT OF VASILEVSKIY.
COMES OUT IN FRONT.
SIT CLEARED.
AND TIME WINDS DOWN HERE IN
TAMPA.
FIVE SECONDS REMAINING.
PUCK RETRIEVED BY PETRY.
LIGHTNING STRIKE TWICE!
THE TAMPA BAY LIGHTNING WIN
THEIR SECOND STRAIGHT STANLEY
CUP!
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
♪
>> Kenny: THREE STRAIGHT FOR PAT
MAROON.
>> Eddie: UNBELIEVABLE.
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE CONTINUE ]
>> Brian: HOW ABOUT THE SHOT
BLOCK, THE LAST HALF OF THE
THIRD PERIOD FOR THE TAMPA BAY
LIGHTNING.
GOODROW HAD AT LEAST FOUR.
AND TO BETTER PLAYER AS A HOCKEY
PLAYER, TO BE IN THE MIDDLE OF
THAT PILE.
AND THE REACTION FROM CAREY
PRICE.
>> Kenny: CAREY PRICE IN HIS
14th NATIONAL HOCKEY LEAGUE
SEASON, HIS FIRST TRIP TO THE
STANLEY CUP FINAL.
>> Eddie: AND HE GAVE HIS TEAM A
CHANCE TO WIN TONIGHT, GUYS.
YOU THINK BACK TO GAME FOUR, HE
CALLED HIMSELF OUT AFTER GAME
THREE, HE SAYS HE NEEDS TO BE
BETTER.
HE WAS BETTER IN GAME FOUR.
HE WAS GOOD ENOUGH TO WIN IN
GAME FIVE.
BUT LIKE SO MANY OTHER T
IT'S NOT AS EASY TO SCORE AS YOU
THINK AGAINST THE LIGHTNING.
THE LIGHTNING WIN A 1-0 GAME IN
A CLIMPBCLINCHING SCENARIO.
>> Kenny: ANDREI VASILEVSKIY TIE
AN NHL RECORD, HIS SIXTH
STRAIGHT SHUTOUT
CLINCHING GAME.
>> Eddie: INCREDIBLE.
AND HE HAS TO BE THE CONN SMYTHE
WINNER FOR ME, CONSIDERING WHAT
HE WAS ABLE TO DO WITH CLINCHING
SCENARIOS, OFTEN OVERLOOKED
BECAUSE THERE'S SO MUCH STAR
POWER ON THIS LIGHTNING TEAM.
HE DESERVES THE RESPECT AND THE
RECOGNITION.
AND TO ME, HE IS THE CONN SMYTHE
WINNER.
WE'LL SEE IF THAT PLAYS OUT THAT
WAY.
THIS TEAM IS NOT THE SAME IF
THEY DON'T HAVE ANDREI
VASILEVSKIY IN GOAL.
>> Brian: WE JUST SAW ALEX SHAKE
HANDS WITH SHEA WEBER, THE
CAPTAIN OF THE MONTREAL
CANADIENS, UNABLE TO PLAY THE
LAST COUPLE OF GAMES BECAUSE OF
A SHOT BLOCK.
BACK IN GAME TWO.
>> Kenny: KILLORN GREW UP IN MON
THALIA, HE WAS A CANADIENS FAN
AS A YOUNGSTER.
>> Eddie: AND THE LIGHTNING
MISSED HIM.
BUT THEY WERE ABLE TO FIND WAYS
TO WIN.
AND IT SPEAKS TO THE DEPTH OF
THEIR CLUB.
IT WASN'T THE STARS THAT WON IT
FOR THEM IN THE END.
GUYS LIKE JOHNSON, COLEMAN.
TONIGHT IT'S ROSS COLTON.
THAT MAN RIGHT THERE WAS SHUT
DOWN IN THIS SERIES.
BUT THE DEPTH OF THIS TAMPA BAY
LIGHTNING FOUND A WAY TO WIN THE
SERIES.
TWO GREAT GOALTENDERS RIGHT
THERE, SHOWING THEIR RESPECT FOR
UN WITH THE.
YOU OFTEN WONDER AS YOU GET
OLDER IN YOUR CAREER, WILL YOU
EVER GET THERE AGAIN?
>> Brian: THAT'S THE PART THAT
IS THE MOST DIFFICULT TO DEAL
WITH, FOR GUYS LIKE CAREY PRICE,
FOR SHEA WEBER.
>> Kenny: JON COOPER, THE SIXTH
HEAD COACH IN A POST ORIGINAL
SIX ERA TO WIN BACK-TO-BACK
STANLEY CUPS.
FOUR ARE IN THE HALL OF FAME,
THE OTHER IS STILL ACTIVE.
THERE'S ROSS COLTON.
HE SCORED THE ONLY GOAL TONIGHT,
IN A 1-0 TAMPA BAY VICTORY.
ADDS HIS NAME TO A LIST, WHICH
INCLUDES WAYNE GRETZKY, MARK
MESSIER, BOBBY ORR, GORDIE
WITH A STANLEY CUP WINNING GOAL.
>> IN TAMPA, RIGHT?
I THINK A LOT OF PEOPLE THINK
THEY'RE A TEAM THAT WINS THOSE
HIGH SCORING GAMES, AND THAT IS
INDEED TRUE, BUT BOUCH, WHEN YOU
THINK ABOUT IT, GAME SEVEN,
MAYING THE NEW YORK ISLANDERS.
WHAT DID THEY DO?
THEY WIN A GAME 1-0.
AND NOW TO WIN THE STANLEY CUP
AT HOME IN GAME FIVE, AS JON
COOPER HAS WORDS WITH CAREY
PRICE, THEY'RE ABLE TO WIN A 1-0
GAME.